كشفت اللجنه الوطنيه لمكافحه المخدرات في
السعوديه من تحذيراتها او كثفت من
تحذيراتها من استخدام ماده الشب والمخدره
التي تتسبب في تعزيز السلوك العدواني
واعراض الهلوسه للمتعطي العربيه زارت احد
المراكز العلاجيه للمدمنين الشباب في
السعوديه والتقت عددا من المتعافيين الذين
راووا تجربتهم في تعاطي تلك الماده
المخدرات
قتل والده ووالدته واخته واخيه حرقا بعد
محاصرتهم في المنزل اضافه الى حاله عنف
اخرى صادبه كلها شواهد على ما يرتكبه
متعاطف الشباب من جرائم
ولي معرفه واقع متعاطينا لهذه الماده
المهلكه قمنا بزياره بعضهم في رحلتهم
العلاجيه
استقبلنا عبد الله في غرفته له تاريخ طويل
في التعاطي الذي قاده في الاخير لتعاطي
الشقوق جرعات بسيطه فقط كانت كفيله بقيامه
باعمال عدوانيه
افقدته وعيه وادراكه وحتى ذكرته
حصلت عليها فجاه
قلت انا وينش اللي صاير ايش الموضوع
ماشي
كم سياره ومدري ايش انا سويت الكلام هذا
الكلام
في منزل منتصف الطريق في المنزل رقم واحد
وهو المرحله الاولى التاهيليه في هذا
المنزل هنالك ايضا منزل ثاني وثالث على
حسب المراحل
وتقدمها يبلغ عدد النزلاء 70 20% منهم هم
من مدمنين الشباب وهي نسبه ارتفعت بشكل
كبير جدا خلال السنه الماضيه
احمد هو الاخر بدا رحله ادمانه في سن
الرابعه عشر
يتعافى من الشاب منذ سبعه اشهر تعرف على
الشاب من احدى المسلسلات الامريكيه وتعطه
قبل ثلاث سنوات رغبه في نشوه اعلى الا ان
الشك اصبح عنوان حياته
وقت النوم
بدي اسمع صوتك
تضحك وانا كنت مطنش كنت جالس على الجوال
يمين يسار
ما عندي احد
ومنها الهلال جدتي
هو مو حقيقي
اكثر من اربع حالات في الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
فيها خطوره عاليه وقد تؤدي الى المضاعفات
النفسيه المصاحبه او الهلاوس
[موسيقى]
صغيره جرائم الشبوه هزت حتى مجتمعات
المدمنين انفسهم كثيرون لا يزالون في قاع
الادمان واخرون يبحثون عن من ياخذ بايديهم
لايمالهم بانهم مجرمون وان حدوث الماسات
مساله وقت
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الريال